Kosar graphs are your friends and to
show you why in this segment I'm going
to describe a scientific controversy
from the late 70s this is a debate that
involve some of the most brilliant
clinical investigators at the time and
by the end of this session when we would
talk a little bit more about graphs in
the next segments you will be able to
resolve this controversy by yourself and
you will be convinced that cosa graphs
help us think better the 1970s was a
fascinating decade that will be
remembered for many things but one of
the most important things that have been
doing the early seventies is that for
the first time in human history
millions of women were receiving
estrogens after menopause and this use
of estrogen was encouraged by doctors by
the media by popular books however
investigators were very concerned
because in 1975 and seventy-six there
were some studies that found that women
receiving estrogens had a higher risk of
being diagnosed with endometrial cancer
than women not receiving estrogens and
the question is why there's one obvious
answer possible answer which is that
estrogens cause cancer
but there were two prominent clinical
investigators from Yale Alvin Feinstein
and Ralph Horwich and they propose
another possibility
they said that estrogens did not have to
cause cancer for us to find this
association between as showing news and
canon cancer they said that what might
happen is that estrogens simply lead to
a diagnosis of cancers that were already
present but would not have been
diagnosed in the absence of estrogens
they knew that between 20 and 60 percent
of cancers are silent and asymptomatic
we only find them when we look for them
and estrogen use causes uterine bleeding
in some women so they reason that the
bleeding was leading doctors to diagnose
pre-existing silent cancers and as a
result as sueance users have a higher
rate of diagnosis of cancer even if
estrogens did not cause cancer violence
so what feinstein and harvard said in
their own world is if estrogens provoke
the bleeding that leads to uterine exam
as intim attic uterine cancer is much
more likely to be found in women
receiving estrogens than in those who do
not receive it and they thought that
this could fully explain the association
between estrogen use and endometrial
cancer they refer to this phenomenon as
a certain entire
therefore we have two possible
explanations for the association between
estrogen use and endometrial cancer one
explanation is that estrogens simply
accelerate the diagnosis of existing
cancers and two estrogens actually cause
cancer now these two explains was a very
different implication for clinical
practice and for public health the
question is how how can we distinguish
between these two explanations which one
is responsible for the association
between estrogen use and endometrial
cancer and this is where the debate was
initiated and there were some
discrepancies among investigators that
we are going to discuss now on the one
hand the investigators from Yale they
proposed the following approach they
said well since estrogens make some
women bleed and therefore more likely to
be diagnosed with pre-existing cancer
when we analyze data from these studies
let's restrict the data analysis to
women who bleed whether they're taking
Austrians or not if we do that then all
women in the analysis because they are
they all have bled they all have the
same likelihood of being diagnosed with
cancer if they have an existing cancer
and therefore if we still find an
association between area news and cancer
it must be that estrogens cause cancer
but there were other equally prominent
investigators who disagreed
people like her seljuq Ken Rothman and
Alec Walker from Boston University and
Harvard University said that restricting
to women who bleed was not the solution
they argued that we would find an
association between estrogen and cancer
diagnosis even among women who bleed and
even if estrogens don't cause cancer
as a consequence if that was true then
the approach that was proposed by the
journal investigators could not truly
distinguish between the two possible
explanations we would still have some
form of ascertaining bias and you may be
wondering how it is possible what the
Boston investigator said is seems
counterintuitive because if all women
selected for the analysis the experience
and bleeding then there should be no
association due to differential
ascertainment well we will return to
this question at the end of this lesson
by that time you'll be able to resolve
this problem by yourself